der Hamburger Hafen der wird Chinese zu
einem großen Teil zumindest verkauft an
das chinesische Staatsunternehmen Costco
24,9 Prozent genau das wird jetzt
Chinesisch bei Bild live der Chef der
Europäischen Volkspartei Manfred Weber
und jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten
Morgen schönen guten Tag Herr Weber wenn
sie in Berlin regieren würden in diesen
Deal gestoppt
absolut wir müssen die Lektion lernen
die wir leider Gottes im Moment bei der
Energiefrage mit Russland spüren die
Abhängigkeiten waren zu groß wir zahlen
heute in hohen Preis für diese
Abhängigkeiten und bei China dürfen wir
die gleichen Fehler machen wir müssen
Abhängigkeiten reduzieren wir wollen
Geschäft machen bitte nicht falsch
verstehen wir müssen weiter auf
wirtschaftlich kooperieren ich will auch
dass wir unsere Produkte aus Deutschland
aus Europa weiter nach China verkaufen
aber wir müssen unserer Welt vorbereiten
wo wir die Abhängigkeit gegenüber China
nicht noch weiter erhöhen und deswegen
ist der Einstieg in Hamburg falsch man
stelle sich einfach mal vor wie denn die
Chinesen darauf reagieren würden wenn
deutsche Firmen sagen sie wollen in
China kritische Infrastruktur übernehmen
dann würden die Chinesen sagen kommt er
überhaupt nie in Frage dass europäische
Firmen in China solche kritische
Infrastruktur übernehmen aber wir
Europäer wir lassen das zu und das ist
aus der deutschen Bundesregierung das
muss ich so formulieren ziemlich naiv
dass das so gemacht wird wenn wir jetzt
keine Geschäfte mehr mit Russland machen
und gleichzeitig immer mehr Politiker
wie auch sie sagen wir sollten immer
weniger auch mit China eigentlich machen
wenn wir gleich nicht wissen dass
eigentlich unsere ganze Autoindustrie
dort ihre Autos baut und verkauft
mittlerweile wird er mir Angst und Bange
also welche Geschäfte sollten wir mit
China noch machen
wir sollten mit China weiter Geschäfte
machen das ist für mich klar wir
bestehenden handlungsbeziehungen sind
für beide Seiten gut sind wir bei der
Zeit die Seiten wichtig beide
profitieren davon und deswegen sollten
wir das auch weiter praktizieren ich
will auf diesem Markt nicht verzichten
aber wir dürfen uns nicht naiv in den
politischen Beziehungen aufstellen
nämlich die Fragestellung kritische
Infrastruktur zu verkaufen ist ebenso
als sensibler Bereich wo wir
vernünftiger sein müssen die Hamburger
Hafenbetreiber argumentieren übrigens
damit dass wenn sie das nicht machen
dass dann das gesamte Handelsvolumen
über Rotterdam oder über andere
europäische Häfen abgewickelt wird wo
cosco schon beteiligt ist und die
chinesischen beteiligt sind und für mich
ist das Argument das war endlich
europäische Lösungen brauchen müssen es
wenn BMW oder Volkswagen heute Autos
verkauft nach China dann ist es für die
praktisch egal ob es überhaupt oder über
Rotterdam abliefern wir haben
europäischen Binnenmarkt an europäischen
gemeinsamen Markt auf dem Bearbeiten
deswegen brauchen wir unbedingt endlich
gemeinsame europäische Strategie China
zu beantworten und und die
Herausforderung anzunehmen und wenn sie
die Frage stellen wo verdienen wir
morgen unser dann sage ich ich will
einen Handelsmarkt aufbauen einen Markt
aufbauen mit den freien Demokratie in
der Welt wenn sie in Berlin schauen das
ist der Berliner Regierung bis heute
nicht gelingt einen Handelsvertrag mit
Kanada abzuschließen in sogenannten
seetar-vertrag wir im Europäischen
Parlament haben den bereits bestätigt
haben den bereits durchgewunken der ist
bereits informell vor ab sozusagen in
Kraft gesetzt worden der greift bereits
rechtlich und jetzt müsste eigentlich
Berlin noch den letzte grünes Licht
geben dafür und es wird Woche und Woche
verschoben weil grün und rot nicht in
der Lage sein mit Kanadas ein
Handelsvertrag abzuschließen die stellen
wir ganz einfach die Frage mit wem
sollen wir dann überhaupt noch Handel
treiben wenn nicht mit Ländern mit
Kanada mit Demokratien die so ticken wie
wir ticken deswegen ich plädiere für
eine Freihandelszone der freien Welt der
Demokratien die müssen wir stärken da
müssen wir zusammenarbeiten und da
können wir gut Geld verdienen ist ein
relativ klein leider weil zu wenig
Demokratien auf der Welt gibt eine
relativ kleine Zone der Kanzler der
argumentiert wie die Befürworter dieses
Deals und sagen nein komm also 24 0,9
Prozent dann haben die im Grunde da gar
nichts zu melden aber die kein eigenes
Stimmrecht dort im Hamburger Hafen
können keine Entscheidung alleine
treffen was soll so schlimm sein die
sanieren uns das Ding und in einigen
Jahrzehnten möglicherweise holen wir uns
dass das Teil vom Hamburger Hafen halt
einfach zurück was passiert im
schlimmsten Fall
also zunächst mal alles beginnt mit dem
ersten Schritt und wenn die erstmal drin
sitzen in der Firma dann sitzen die bei
den entscheidenden Gremien mit dabei
deshalb alles beginnt mit dem ersten
Schritt und deswegen sage ich wäre den
Anfängen
Naivität des schlichter schlechter
Ratgeber deswegen jetzt Vorsicht wir
müssen in Europa unsere kritische
Infrastruktur definieren gilt übrigens
auch fürs 5g Netzwerk beim digitalen
Bereich unsere kritische Infrastruktur
definieren und die müssen wir auch unter
europäischen unter westlichen Schutz
stellen übrigens erlauben Sie mir dazu
sagen sie da war nur ein Beispiel Kanada
ich kann Ihnen auch sagen dass wir
derzeit auf europäische Ebenen
Handelsvertrag mit Südamerika aushandeln
da geht es um Brasilien da geht es um
Argentinien Hunderte von Millionen
Menschen große Märkte viele Verbraucher
die europäische Produkte lieben die
unsere Produkte gerne kaufen und auch
bei diesem Abkommen plädiere ich dafür
dieses Handelsabkommen Merkur heißt das
jetzt abzuschließen wir brauchen
Alternativen zu China wir müssen unsere
China Fixiertheit als Deutsche als
europäische Wirtschaft aufgeben dann
haben wir wirtschaftliche Potenziale für
die Zukunft sagt Manfred Weber der Chef
der Europäischen Volkspartei bleiben sie
noch einen kleinen Moment bei uns wir
schauen auf Olaf Scholz noch einmal der
gerade durch Europa reist der ist
aktuell in Griechenland da geht es vor
allen Dingen um Energiepolitik um grünen
Strom aus Athen dass die Bilder dort von
dem Besuch und das gerade nach seiner
Reise nach Frankreich zu Emanuel macron
nach Paris gerade ein paar Stunden von
dort zurück und darauf diesen Besuch
können wir noch mal kurz schauen denn
der war doch recht kühl gibt große
Meinungsverschiedenheiten gerade
zwischen den beiden vor allen Dingen in
Sachen Russland vor allen Dingen in
Sachen in Energiepolitik und die
französische Zeitschrift liberation die
bringt das heute auf den Punkt mit der
Schlagzeile wo man die beiden sieht wie
sie sich den Rücken einander zukehren
und dazu titelt liberation
olala olala hier sehen wir den Titel
herr Weber wie würden sie im Moment das
Verhältnis der beiden beschreiben
tja
also Europa Politiker schaue ich damit
sehr viel Sorge drauf
weil wenn Deutschland Frankreich wenn
die Achse zwischen Berlin und Paris
nicht funktioniert kann Europa nicht
funktionieren und deswegen sind wir alle
sehr besorgt ob der Spannung in die da
entstehen
Emmanuel macron geht auch sicher
manchmal sein eigenen Weg ist jetzt auch
mit der einfachste Partner aber er ist
überzeugt Europäern will Europa
gestalten es war in den letzten Jahren
immer bewiesen auf der anderen Seite
haben wir leider diese Bundesregierung
im letzten Jahr erlebt im ersten Jahr
ihre Amtszeit erlebt die nach Beginn des
Kriegs zunächst mal Mittelosteuropa
schwer enttäuscht hat unsere
partnerdaten weil wir gegenüber der
Ukraine so zurückhaltend waren die
Waffenlieferungen am Anfang ja
verweigert worden sind und jetzt Stück
für Stück mehr geliefert wird wir haben
die Diskussion um die um die
gaspreisdeckel um die
Energiepreisentwicklung erlebt wo
Deutschland ziemlich alleine immer
wieder bei den blockieren dabei war um
die überschießenden Spekulationsgewinne
der Konzerne einfach abzufangen und
unseren ja unseren Verbrauchern unsere
Handwerkern unsere Industrie einfach die
Bedeutung zu geben die notwendig ist in
der jetzigen Krisenzeit und wir haben
erlebt der doppelwumms diese 200
Milliarden Euro die wurden nicht
abgestimmt es ist natürlich das Recht
Deutschlands auch ihrem Verbrauchern und
Betrieben zu helfen steht außer Frage
aber man muss reden miteinander man muss
mit Polen man muss mit Frauen treffen
muss mit der Kommission reden und ich
habe jetzt drei Beispiele
herausgegriffen wo leider Gottes die
Bundesregierung sehr egoistisch in einer
gewissen Art und Weise unterwegs war und
nicht europäisch abgestimmt vorgegangen
ist und das macht Sorge wir sind in
Krisenzeiten wir sind den Kriegszeiten
in Europa deswegen brauchen wir umso
mehr Bundesregierung die
partnerschaftlich auftreten Manfred
Weber Chef der Europäischen Volkspartei
auch er benutzt das Adjektiv naiv wenn
es um den China von Scholz am Hamburger
Hafen geht und auch erblickt mit großer
Sorge auf unsere wirtschaftliche Zukunft
in Deutschland vielen Dank
ich bedanke mich
[Musik]